ramaa could be famous for its
picturesque wooden houses and narrow
alleys after all the town in
southwestern finland has been declared a
UNESCO World Heritage Site
instead Rama is making headlines for a
nuclear power plant located just 10
kilometers outside the town it's been in
service for three decades and a third
reactor is under construction soon the
world's first-ever final repository for
nuclear waste will be located here -
it'll be buried deep underground and
surrounded by a layer of solid rock the
plan is to store nuclear waste there for
100,000 years in most countries a
permanent nuclear waste storage facility
would spark protests or at least be seen
as a cause for concern yet talking to
the people of Rama reveals just the
opposite politicians tell us it's safe
than it is it's the right location I
trust the technicians finish swamis they
don't seem to be worried about the
potential risks one of the passengers on
this bus thinks otherwise though he is
not happy that the world's first final
repository for nuclear waste will be
located in Finland I'm rather saying
that we are doing it so fast of course
we should put the nuclear waste
somewhere but but not so it's it's not
so easy
we want to see where the spent fuel will
be stored so we travel underground to a
depth of 420 meters below sea level
these billion-year-old
rock walls are supposed to contain the
radiation we're joined by a geologist
and a power plant employee and we can go
in now to the tunnel and see what kind
of these holes are the plan is to drill
hundreds of eight metre deep holes into
the rock that will enable nuclear fuel
rods encased in copper to be inserted it
has many stages where we gather all the
research information what we have and
then make a decision that is it possible
to make the hole or not it's a maze of
tunnels and it will take 100 years until
all of Finland's nuclear waste will be
sealed in here and 100,000 years until
the radiation subsides but who knows for
sure what will happen in 100,000 years I
don't know the rock itself stays as it
is if there's well of course if there's
an ice age then we are going to have
some rock lifting going all rock is
being put down but otherwise it's it's
hard to see if you think backwards the
same time there are millions of things
that have happened during that time but
this will be safe not even the fear of
an ice age seems to be able to rattle
the Finnish people even if that prospect
could destroy the tunnel system
I think anyhow this is better placed and
let me keep the radioactive used full
fuel outside but Tonya Buchanan has
misgivings we meet Tanya and her
children in Ramah near the nuclear power
plant
she knows that Finn's used lots of
electricity but her family is an
exception they use wood to heat their
house and sauna but will this be enough
she worries about the next generation
nothing that dangers can be in safe 400
percent sir so many so many years so
long time so it's too risky if people
would think about that even a moment
they would understand it the nuclear
fuel will be contained behind a rock
wall and surrounded by a wall of silence
the operators will not be installing
public warning signs it might be better
to be forgotten because if we think of
the fact words the time we have already
difficulties to understand what the
Egyptian's before I do tell us with a
with their language so the plan seems to
be to try to forget about the storage
facility everything's already settled
and the local residents know that a
protest would fall on deaf ears in this
area they are afraid there has been so
much pressure for those who are who have
sorted these things out as we returned
home doubts remain for instance how
thick will the rock walls need to be to
withstand the forces of nature it's a
question that does not seem to be at the
forefront of most people's minds
you